au plan politique on notera
essentiellement aujourd'hui une prise de
position très ferme de Jacques Chirac
président du RPR et cofondateur de l'UNM
l'Union pour la nouvelle majorité contre
la politique instaurée par le président
François mitteran c'était une conférence
de presse la première depuis les
élections Jacques Chirac a expliqué
pourquoi il fallait à son avis un
contrepoid au pouvoir présidentiel
actuel Jacques Lenoir pour Jacques
Chirac les législatives ne seront pas le
3è tour de l'élection présidentielle le
vote du 10 mai doit être respecté ell
doiv en revanche permettre à l'assemblée
de contrôler le gouvernement pour
préserver a-t-il dit les principes de
liberté et pour éviter ce qu'il appelle
l'aventure critiquant déjà les premiers
résultats de l'action gouvernementale
conséquence économique notamment il a
demandé au nouveau pouvoir de sortir de
l'ambiguité c'est-à-dire d'indiquer s'il
est prêt à gouverner avec les
communistes et aussi de définir
nettement son programme un programme
qu'il juge
inquiétant manifestement les mesures
prévues dans le projet socialiste sont
de nature à casser la machine
économique il faut à tout prix que la
composition de la nouvelle Assemblée
permette de conjurer ce
danger la France n'est pas un
laboratoire où des apprentis pourraent
sans danger aucun se livrer au gré de
leurs inspirations d'ailleurs
contradictoires à des
expérience dont les effets l'histoire le
prouve seraient irréversibles
vous comprenez pourquoi aujourd'hui je
suis inquiet pour la France vous
comprenez aussi pourquoi je suis résolu
à me battre dans un esprit de très large
union pour qu'une nouvelle majorité à
l'Assemblée soit le garant du progrès et
de la liberté pour notre
pays et puis second argument de
jacquesirac qu'une victoire de la gauche
aux prochaines élections mettrait fin à
l'actuel équilibre politique dans le
pays entre la majorité et
l'opposition aujourd'hui cet équilibre
est en passe de se rompre
totalement
et nous risquons de nous trouver demain
si l'on n'y prend pas garde avec la
totalité des pouvoirs publics
et une très grande partie des forces que
je viens d'évoquer
entre les mains des seuls représentants
de 52 % des Français ceci pour
schématiser naturellement alors je dis
que ce serait un très grave danger pour
l'équilibre de notre démocratie et
lorsque je vois ce qu'est le projet
socialiste lorsque je n'entends aucun
démenti à l'affirmation selon laquelle
les communistes pourraient participer au
pouvoir et au gouvernement au lendemain
de ces élections alors je dis que ce
serait également un danger très grave
pour nos libertés et en tous les cas
pour notre progrès économique